kristen
is next in iowa hi kristin how are you
i'm well how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
so i'm looking for some book
recommendations
for father's day and i was hoping that
each of you could kind of
weigh given your professional background
so
my husband is transitioning away from
a technical role at his job
more into managerial and leadership
and um he's very hungry to learn
about the business aspect
of the business um so he's been
listening to podcasts and reading books
um who's he listening to oh i knew you
would ask me that um
who's he reading um he's reading like
getting things done um
uh patrick lindsey yep
yeah yeah okay um and
so for dave i was wondering if you could
kind of give
recommendations for like the logistics
of running an
office like day-to-day meetings
how often are you checking in with
people um
you know like
evaluations and that kind of stuff
uh his company should have systems and
processes in place on that
if they're moving him into leadership
they should have a set of standards that
they run
with on that uh that's so tactical
that it you know most leadership books
are not
written with uh do this do that do this
in terms of that kind of they give you
they're more conceptual patrick is a
friend of mine
anything that patrick lincione writes is
worth reading
um okay his um the the one i would start
i would pick up two books of his the uh
the ideal team player
which talks about hiring people that are
hungry humble and smart
and um and uh the advantage
which is probably one of his best books
he ever did the advantage
uh uh i can probably
send you those um and
i think we've got them here and um john
maxwell's 21 irrefutable laws of
leadership and i'll throw in my book
entree leadership which was the number
one how we run our business
um and very kind thank you
yeah we'll put those four together but
basically uh
jim collins anything he writes good to
great is a classic
yeah um anything that um
john maxwell writes but he writes a book
every week it's hard to keep up with him
and uh uh uh pat lindsey on anything he
writes simon cynic stuff is good
he's an excellent writer good thought
later his new one called infinite game
is a rock star book
it is really good uh when i
when i was leading teams um books that
were important for me
were there was two books by henry cloud
one was boundaries
and one was necessary endings for a
leader that were two powerful books
definitely
i can't think of her name she wrote a
book called i think it's radical
integrity radical honesty about having
hard conversations that spoke to me
in a real good way yeah and then there's
two books i've read recently that were
outstanding one is
the obstacles the way by ryan holliday
and another is i don't want to talk
about it by terrence real
which um it's a book on male depression
which sounds like it wouldn't apply but
it's really about
leaders looking inside themselves and
being able to
take care of the human being that's now
a leader over other human beings and if
a leader's not well
they spew that stuff all over the human
beings that work
underneath them and work side by side
with them but if a person can be well
especially a guy in a leadership role
then the folks around them have the
opportunity to be well too
now lincione the thesis of his book we
found to be true in almost all these
other books we mentioned feed into that
same thing the thesis of the advantage
is organizational mental health
the ability to do conflict well without
toxicity
and we do conflict all the time around
here it's like a full-time job
um and we're pretty good at it you were
just hitting me during the highly honed
highly honed skill but the uh uh but the
ability to do conflict well
and drive to excellence without harming
all the players
you know in the process and um
uh and and you know work through
differences and those kinds of things
is more of an advantage for a company
than smart people more of an advantage
than a uh
a product that you have a trademark on
or a copyright on or a patent on
people think those are the kinds of
things that are the magic sauce the
magic sauce is people working well
together
that's the sauce and it just happens so
rarely
that when you do it it gives you an
unprecedented
advantage in the marketplace and that's
why lincione calls that book
the advantage so it's it but all of
these things feed into that
right playing well with others is a
skill that it that gives you a distinct
advantage and knowing how to do it
good really neat question kristen thanks
for calling in kelly i'll pick up we'll
get some of those out to you and you can
backfill
with the rest of them this is the dave
ramsey show